number one the first few decades are
dominated by these shrubs blocking away
the sunlight from everyone else but over
time step two watch these resilient pine
trees slowly overtake them and deny them
their precious sunlight and what happens
as a result look their downfall brings
forth a complete ecosystem change and
then step three spruce trees start to
appear this changes the game why well
these are more shade tolerant and let's
see yes they take over the ecosystem
from the pine trees a beautifully done
story in such a little simulation I
absolutely love it of course any
self-respecting virtual world will also
contain other objects not just the
vegetation and the simulator says no
problem just Chuck him in there and
we'll just react accordingly